- 1+1 стає рупором нової влади...
- Це повна нісенітниця.
- Ви хочете стати мером Києва?
- Всьому свій час.
- У вас є особисто конфлікт із паном Кличком?
- Ні.
- Чи є у Вас фото з президентом?
(сміється) - Так, є.
- Портрет президента в кабінеті?
- Президент же сказав, що не треба.
Політична боротьба за Київ або конфлікт
Зе команди з мером Києва Віталієм  Кличком.
Про це будемо говорити з Олександром Ткаченком -
гендиректором холдингу "1+1 media" і дев’ятим (номером)
у списку партії "Слуга народу".
- Доброго дня.
- Доброго.
- У Вас особисто є конфлікт з паном Кличком?
- Ні.
Мер Києва  Віталій Кличко заявив, що
офіс президента Зеленського не хоче його бачити на посаді глави КМДА
і нібито ви є одним із претендентів на цю посаду.
Мені здається, це не діалог,
який відбувається на сьогоднішній день
з приводу ситуації, яка сталася в Києві, а, скоріше,
монолог діючого мера з суспільством.
Тому що суспільство всіляко показує, що є проблеми в місті.
Принаймні, про це говорять останні результати виборів  до ВР по Києву,
коли перемогли слуги народу в 13-ти округах.
У тому числі й кандидатів, яких особисто підтримував діючий мер.
Тому що розмови стосовно претензій щодо дій мерії прозвучали,
очевидно, у приватних розмовах між Кличком і керівником офісу,
які  мер вирішив винести на люди.
Таким чином це стало публічною дискусією.
Тому я жодного конфлікту не бачу,
принаймні, мені здається, що це намагання
самого мера діючого цей конфлікт спровокувати.
Чому правляча партія не хоче бачити пана Кличка
на посаді глави КМДА або, можливо, мера Києва?
Питання про мера має вирішуватися на нормальних виборах.
Чи будуть вони достроковими, чи строковими, я не знаю.
Стосовно глави КМДА в законі  існує колізія певна.
Цей закон
передбачає, що при зміні президента має змінюватися голова КМДА.
Ці посади розділені за законом.
І це право президента вирішувати, хто  має бути головою КМДА.
Діючий мер був на посаді упродовж останніх 5 років.
Він мав усі можливості прийняти нормальний європейський закон про столицю,
де б цей рудимент у вигляді КМДА був відсутній.
Має бути, на наш погляд, нормальний виконком,
діючий мер і префект, який виконує  наглядові функції з боку  глави держави.
Крім того, має бути нормальне самоврядування.
Ми на сьогоднішній день забули про те, що районні ради, районні виконкоми відсутні.
Тобто якщо тротуар десь зламався в Святошино чи на Троєщині,
ці питання мають вирішувати в Київраді на Хрещатику.
Віталій Кличко  заявив, що нібито від нього вимагали
координувати всі його дії або з вами, або з бізнесменом Вавришем.
Чи можете Ви це спростувати або підтвердити?
Про те, що  я маю координувати дії з Кличком, я почув від Кличка.
Від нікого більше я не чув.
Стосовно Вавриша, він сам, здається відповідав, що він
був присутній на розмові з Кличком
стосовно можливого переїзду адміністрації в музей на Європейській площі.
Ви ініціювали створення концепції розвитку столиці. Навіщо Вам це?
От тут висить плакат.
Так виглядає Поділ, принаймні рік тому.
Київ - моє рідне місто і мені трошки  соромно за те, що відбувається в місті.
Ми мали дискусію упродовж двох років з багатьма
урбаністами, архітекторами, візіонерами щодо того, як має розвиватися місто.
Останні 5 років  - це роки втрачених можливостей.
Місто забудовується безсистемно.
І зрозуміти, що ці забудови несуть комфорт, безпеку
і благоустрій для громадян, достатньо важко.
Тобто всього цього немає і мені здається, що ця дискусія на часі.
Ви заявляли, що в Києві тотальна корупція,
що бюджетом міста керує навіть не мер Києва,
а люди, яких називають "смотрящімі".
Чому ви так вважаєте?
Ми робили достатньо багато матеріалів.
Наші журналісти стосовно корупції в місті, яка
має як побутовий характер, так і системний.
На жаль, ні для кого не таємниця в Києві,
хто, власне, містом керує.
Є так званий " тіньовий офіс", яким керує пан Столар
- один із номерів в партії " Опозиційна платформа-За життя".
І коли ми проводили кампанію в місті з 13-ма кандидатами "Слуги народу",
одною з трьох головних претензій до діючої влади від жителів Києва була корупція.
Віталій Кличко планує судитися з каналом 1+1.
На думку мера, проти нього канал 1+1 веде кампанію з дискредитації.
Ми, коли побачимо позовну заяву і стосовно чого
вона, власне, направлена,
тоді зможемо відповісти.
За свої слова ми відповідаємо. Ми чули багато
погроз і з боку колишнього президента Порошенка під час виборчої кампанії.
Але найбільше, на що він був здатний
вже під час парламентської кампанії,
це розповсюджувати  листівки стосовно 1+1, які ми нехороші.
1+1 стає рупором нової влади.
Чи можете Ви це спростувати чи то підтвердити?
Це повна нісенітниця. Жодним рупором ми не стали і не будемо.
Це позиція не тільки моя, а в першу чергу журналістів,
тому що в нас достатньо імунітету спротиву
будь-яким зазіханням на незалежність редакційної  політики в колективі.
За каналом 1+1 стоїть олігарх - пан Ігор Коломойський.
Він не стоїть. Він - власник.
Як Ви будете реагувати, якщо, приміром, пан Коломойський буде втручатися
в діяльність  каналу 1+1 з приводу того,
як повідомляти або інформувати суспільство про діяльність нової Верховної ради?
Ви знаєте, коли Коломойський став власником в 2010 році,
в нього відбувся  перший діалог з колективом ТСН, знайомство.
Відтоді він, як мені здається, чудово зрозумів,
що якщо він і може мати якийсь вплив
на редакційну політику в колективі,
то це переважно через діалог з журналістами.
Він із ними періодично зустрічається,
десь раз на рік або два рази на рік, і веде таку дискусію.
Канал буде критикувати правлячу владу?
Він вже критикує.
Ну, приміром, остання заява, яка була стосовно відставки Богдана,
- в нас був достатньо критичний сюжет
стосовно характеру того, як це відбувалося.
Вас як журналіста не лякають слова пана Богдана
про те, що владі для спілкування з народом
ЗМІ як посередники не потрібні?
Не лякають, тому що це його особиста точка зору.
Пан Богдан вважає, що з передвиборчою кампанією впоралися
і можна так далі без преси працювати.
Я так не думаю. Ще раз: це особиста точка зору Богдана.
Але велика частка правди в його словах є.
Тому що, в принципі, пряма комунікація,
яку побудувала виборча кампанія Зеленського під час цієї
виборчої кампанії,
показала, що старі методи впливу на аудиторію не працюють.
З точки зору охоплення Порошенко щонайменше мав
набагато більше охоплення телевізійного традиційного, але це не спрацювало,
тому що в першу чергу мова йшла навіть не стільки про соціальні мережі,
скільки про довіру до того чи іншого кандидата.
Перемога Зеленського - це вдала діджитал-кампанія,
вдалий серіал "Слуга народу", ефект від багаторічної трансляції  "95-го кварталу"?
Це прояв свободи і прояв тотального distrust –
недовіри до колишніх  очільників при владі,
які намагалися, в тому числі, під час цієї виборчої кампанії
посіяти розкол у суспільстві з приводу того,
хто правий, хто неправий, хто найбільший патріот - інакше зникне Україна тощо.
І це також наш вибір, який ми можемо в разі потреби зробити ще раз.
Ви готові очолити комітет Верховної ради з гуманітарних питань?
Принаймні така дискусія ведеться.
Ми запропонували концепцію
не просто пострадянської традиції розподілу цих напрямків
на культуру, спорт чи медіа,
а те, що в західному цивілізованому світі існує певний час -
це гуманітарна політика.
Це, власне, про те, хто ми є, яким чином держава
цінує цінність людського потенціалу
і  яким чином  ми можемо розвивати креативні індустрії,
які упродовж багатьох років виглядали в вигляді  жебраків.
Що  Ви можете зробити для туристичної галузі?
Україна, яку має знати світ.
Туристи, які прилітають в міжнародний аеропорт Бориспіль, вони нічого не бачать, що таке Україна…
У Грузії галузь туризму на сьогодні складає двозначну  цифру в економіці,
в ВВП стосовно доходів, які приносить Грузії туризм.
В Україні жалюгідні цифри.
В Чорнобиль до відомого серіалу їздило кілька тисяч чоловік.
Дай Бог, щоб після цього серіалу, можливо, приїде тисяч 50.
Насправді ця територія при нормальному ставленні
може переварити до півмільйона людей,
які можуть приїхати тільки в Чорнобиль.
Я не кажу  вже про наші пустелі, замки і такі міста, як Львів, Одеса тощо.
Спорт і Київ. Спортивна інфраструктура.
Багато чого очікували  від мера Кличка.
Що пропонує нова влада?
Для мене було певним відкриттям зрозуміти,
що провідні наші спортсмени напряму фінансуються міністерством  спорту.
Тобто в міністерстві сидить якийсь клерк, можливо, міністр,
і розписує їм календарний план змагань.
Уявити собі в нормальних європейських державах це неможливо,
тому що цим займаються федерації і є певні важелі,
які спонукають у тому числі бізнесменів вкладати кошти і в інфраструктуру.
Ми раді, що і спортсмени, і представники федерацій
давно вже хочуть реформи.
Якою вона буде, покаже найближчим часом наша дискусія.
За яких  умов ви відмовитеся співпрацювати з новою владою?
Якщо почнуть ходити гроші.
Якщо  будуть якісь речі, пов’язані з територіальними поступками.
Якщо будуть речі, які протирічать
моєму розумінню  принципів свободи слова чи прав людини.
Ви давно, я так думаю, думали про своє місце в політиці.
Чому ви  вирішили зробити це саме з командою Зеленського?
Я, в принципі, не думав про своє місце в політиці.
Можу перехреститися точно.
Але цей  шанс, який сьогодні з’явився,
і цей великий ступінь довіри до Зеленського
говорить про те, що  в суспільстві зміни перезріли
і є можливість перезавантаження системи серйозна.
Якщо справа дійде до того, що Вам запропонують посаду глави КМДА
або ви вирішите балотуватися на посаду  мера Києва,
що буде з вашою роботою на 1+1?
Усьому  свій час. На роботі з 1+1 це в будь-якому  разі
позначиться моє депутатство, але  також найближчим  часом
будуть відомі подробиці стосовно цієї історії.
Лакмусовий папірець для нової влади. Що це для вас?
Коли почнуть  повертатися громадяни з-за кордону
в Україну, тому що тут буде добре жити і цікаво працювати.
Дуже дякую.